jailed belarusian journalist roman
pratacevic has addressed a news
conference in minsk in what the
opposition says is
another statement made under duress mr
protoservice said he was in good health
and that he has not
been beaten he was arrested last month
after his flight to lithuania was forced
to land in minsk
this is the third time he's appeared in
front of the press
previously he admitted to plotting to
overthrow president
lukashenko
dw reporter alexandra bogus lavskaya
in minsk was at that to press conference
uh welcome
how did rahman practise see
good afternoon yes it was really
hard press conference for me from
emotional point of view
romantic savage wanted to look home
he wanted to look confident but i feel
like sometimes
he really feel upset about his position
he wanted to convince
us independent journalists that he
really regrets
about what he's done but we don't really
believe
him we understand that he is under
pressure and the torture and we cannot
really
understand what he went through um
and um it was really it hurts me to see
him in in this position
i also think that for the uh for the
yeah as i say why do you presume that he
has been uh tortured
um so i mean like a psychological
torture yes he demonstrated that he has
no damages
like um he demonstrated his hands
and he'll look like really like great
and um
like normal but uh i think that um
people cannot change
uh their minds so quickly like he was
uh the administrator of the big uh
telegram channel he was like the
one of these uh who control the protest
in belarus and now he
said how how he respect lukashenko
i don't really believe in such changes
that's why i think that he's under real
pressure right now
and why does the the the belarusian
regime make uh mr president
make these press statements
um i think that they wanted to fix
what they've done they realized that
nowadays the international reaction is
quite serious
uh they have problem with a traffic
right now and
you know the belarusian regime often
uses for propaganda purposes
people like rahman like people who were
in the opposition
and now he's silent like he respect
uh they wanted to convince over the
world and the beloved people
uh that al kashanka has won but it's not
and i don't really think that this works
uh for the international community and
for the below some people as well
i'm so where does the protest movement
go from here uh briefly if you don't
mind
uh i don't really understand the
question sorry the the protest movement
uh of which roman precipice was such a
large part now that he has apparently
changed sides
does that do the protest continue
uh so uh of course there are no like big
protests on the streets
right now um because we have a lot of
repression right now they
um pass a new repression law
uh in belarus and people are frightening
to uh
to work in belarus it's really not safe
to live in belarus right now i can say
that
um but i don't really think that the
russian people
and now think that okay lukas venka has
won
and um they wanted to uh protest
they did not accept this regime and
i think it's like the question of time
when uh
this process may continue
okay thank you so much for for joining
us alexandra uh alexandre
uh bogus lavskaya in minsk
you